oui bonsoir en effet vous posez la
question tout à l'heure à mon challenger
de savoir ce qui les fait la différence
ce qui a fait la différence dans le
territoire de belfort c'est la duperie
la tromperie de la part du parti les
républicains qui a élu un faux tracts
vendredi soir dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres de la circonscription un faux
tracts baptisé les insoumis qui appelait
à voter contre moi les insoumis ont
porté plainte contre x pour l'instant et
moi je déposerai dès demain matin un
recours en annulation auprès du tribunal
administratif de besançon
je le fais parce que moi je me battrai
toujours pour que la démocratie triomphe
dans le territoire de belfort
je ne laisserai pas une petite caste
trichet duper les électeurs pour troquer
leur choix c'est ce qui s'est
malheureusement passé sur cette
circonscription
donc vous savez j'aurais perdu la
régulière j'aurais été le premier à
féliciter mon adversaire
là nous avons été battus sur un tract
qui est influencé une partie des
électeurs des insoumis qui a fait gamme
12% au premier tour
plus de 200 ont été ont été ainsi du p
donc je déposerai des mots matin un
recours au nom de l'éthique au nom des
principes au nom de mes valeurs de vie
je le dire parce que ça c'est christine
arron gendre yann boukhara et damien
meslot vous êtes un mauvais joueur
j'ai pas peur de prendre ça parce qu'il
ya une partie de la population celle qui
veut justement plus de cette classe
politique
cette classe politique qui profitent du
système qui pensent qu'on peut raconter
n'importe quoi aux gens et bien cette
population là et la tente d'avoir des
élus qui portent comme ça le temps d'art
de l'éthique et de lacs et de la qualité
de la vie politique
on ne peut pas impunément jeu quand on
voit des gens des républicains distribué
des tracts du front national avec des
infos traque des insoumis dont toute la
circonscription
ça ne peut pas ça ne peut pas être
quelque chose de correct donc vous
couvrez avec votre gel obligatoires
c'est simplement un tract distribué par
l'équipe des républicains selon ça je
vous assure que 200 électeurs des
insoumis ont été abusés par cette
démarche les insoumis ont porté plainte
on verra cette partie pénale entre les
républicaine a soumis et en ce qui me
concerne je considère que ça influence
et alors qu'on a fait un très bon score
par ailleurs sur la ville de belfort on
a fait 53 % sur la ville de belfort et
c'est effectivement de la commune rurale
où on a eu plus de
difficulté et donc les gens qu'on a pu
rattraper encore le samedi on l'a fait
mais il n'y a pas assez de temps pour
pouvoir corriger cette ce tract
dernières minutes de nos adversaires
particulièrement malhonnête puisqu'elle
a repris en même temps le sigle en fait
d un sommet donc je me bagarrais tentant
que j'ai un souffle de vie je me bagarre
pour que l'éthique l'emportent mars